Dans les pubs
Les fuites urinaires, pourquoi dramatiser ?
C'est fréquent non?
Pas de tabou !
Ah! Parlons-en !
Dans la vie
Ah...les fuites urinaires ! Parlons-en !
Ah bah non, non merci en fait
Mais si  ! Les fuites urinaires, tu en as , j'en ai, ce n'est pas un tabou
Ok Mélanie on ne s'est pas vues depuis un mois, j'aimerais bien parler d'autre chose pour une fois tu vois ?
Tu sais quoi , j'en ai en ce moment même je vais te montrer !
Ah bah non j'ai pas envie de voir ça tu vois *rire gêné*
Mais ça arrête pas de couler j'adore !
SU PER !
Dans les pubs!
Mon premier plan Khüne, c'était waouh un grand costaud, à croquer !
Dans la vie !
Mon dernier plan cul c'était waouh c'était avec un grand costaud
Ton dernier plan Kühne, tu veux dire.
Oui mon plan Kühne, Ouais. *rire gêné*
Bon bref, on a ken toute la nuit
Plutôt 2 fois Kühne.
Attend je te rappelle
Ok tu veux parler de cornichons.
Là. Tes cornichons, tu vois. Et bah des gros cornichons, comme ça là et ben moi j'adore ça
Dans les pubs
Chez Tati, t'as tout. Chez Tati t'as tout
Dans la vie
Chez Tati, t'as tout. - FERMEZ -LAAA !
Non on dit plus ça. Non on le dit plus
Chez Tati, ta gueule. Ok ?
Chez Tati, ta gueule
Ça c'est pas mal
Dans les pubs
Entre amis, en famille : Mots-mêlés
Qui sera le plus rapide
*Pouet*  Mots-mêlés
Dans la vie
Mots-mêlés
Mais vous allez où?
Je vais jouer à Fortinite
Je vais sur Tik-Tok
Bon bah
Il ne reste plus que nous deux.
J'ai pensé à d'autres petits jeux
Oui les Mots-mêlés
Tiens regarde!
Divorce
Non ça rentre pas
Si, si ça rentre très bien
Les pubs
Sarah, rêvait d'une carrière dans le web.
Elle n'a pas ménagé ses efforts pour y arriver
Mais on dirait bien que ce soir. Sa nouvelle vie vient de commencer.
Dans la vie
Sarah rêvait d'une carrière dans le web
Elle n'a pas ménagé ses efforts
pour y arriver. Et, on dirait bien que
ce soir, sa nouvelle vie
n'arrivera jamais.
Elle va faire un stage non-rémunéré avec
des tâches ingrates, sans avoir une once
de reconnaissance de son patron. Une carrière
dans le Web ? Non mais franchement,
Sarah aurait du faire de la comptabilité.
Ça au moins ça embauche.
Dans les pubs !
- Ah t'as vu ? Y'a les nouveaux voisins qui emménagent !
- Attends, attends. On va s'marrer : j'vais leur dire
à quel point on met de crédit pour la maison.
- Bonjour !
Dans la vie
- Eh j'suis votre voisin ! J'ai eu le taux pour ma maison
à 1,8 !
- Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça nous foute en fait ?
- Pas trop dég ?
- J'ai plus du tout envie d'emménager là en fait.
Dans les pubs
*musique*
Vous avez l'énergie de rendre le monde plus harmonieux, avec...
Dans la vie
*musique*
*bruit d'extincteur*
- Hahahahaha ! *rire diabolique*
La ville est dans le noir !
HAHAHA - Je vais peut-être appeler la police moi je...
- Je déteste
l'électricité haha !
Dans les pubs !
- Tiens, ton zéro argent de poche
pour faire plein de zéro dépenses !
- Zéro, trop cool !
- Ouais, t'achètera zéro baskets !
Dans la vie !
- Tiens, ton zéro argent de poche
pour faire pleins de zéro dépenses !
- Non mais arrête avec ça.
- Ah, je crois que votre zéro maman va bientôt rentrer !
- Mais papa, ça fait déjà un an que
maman t'a quitté.
- Je sais ! *pleure*
C'est parce que j'ai un zéro métier, j'suis sûr !
Dans les pubs ! La revente facile avec
vendezvotrevoiture.fr
VendezVotreVoiture.fr !
Dans la vie !
vendezvotrevoiture.fr !!
- Et coupez ! Tiens c'est ta fiche de paie ça.
- Merci. Ah, je crois que vous vous êtes trompé sur mon salaire par contre.
- Eh t'a cru quoi ? Que t'étais Jennifer Jawrence ?
- Regarde le budget de la pub on peut même pas tourner devant un vrai concessionnaire
on a un vieux fond vert tout pété ! Estime toi heureuse hein ?!
- Ok, donc c'est vendezvotrecul.fr le truc quoi.
- T'as dit quoi ?
- Non rien.
- J'préfère. Allez on remballe les gars! *siffle*
Allez allez !
Dans les pubs
- Je peux vous poser quelques questions ?
- Oui !
- À toi aussi ?
*rire* - Oui
- Qui est la personne la plus curieuse au monde ?
- Et ben....
*rires*
- Donc qui ?
- Moi !!
Dans la vie !
- Qui est la personne la plus curieuse au monde ?
- Allez, faut répondre !
- 'faut faire une phrase en fait avec des mots
- Tu veux pas parler ?
- Tu penses quoi de la situation des gilets-jaunes ?
- MAIS C'EST QUOI CES INTERVIEWS ?
- J'AI FAIT UNE ÉCOLE DE JOURNALISME MOI hein !
- ET C'EST QUOI CE MICRO SÉRIEUX ?
- ET IL SE MARRE !!
- On arrête les enfants... j'abandonne !
Dans les pubs !
- Au début, mes parents ça les stressait d'acheter du neuf !
- J'ai dû intervenir.
- Je leur ai dit ; "Hey les parents Vinci Immobilier for you, ça vous dit rien, on connaît pas ?"
Dans la vie !
- Hey, les parents, "Vinci Immobilier For You", ça vous dit rien ? On connaît pas ?
- Qu'est-ce que tu racontes toi ?!
- T'as 10 ans !!
- T'y connais quoi à l'immobilier FRANCHEMENT ?
- Qu'est-ce qu'elle dit là, encore la petite ?
- Ah oui, alors ben notre gamine elle nous apprend comment acheter un appartement tu sais ?!
- Mais elle me souuule !
- Je vais la mettre en foyer, moi hein ?!!
- VA FAIRE TES DEVOIRS UN PEU !
- Mais ces quoi ces gamins là !?
-Ah le melon là !
Dans les pubs
- Papa, maman j'ai quelque chose à vous dire....
- Alexa, recommence ma musique.
*musique de l'enceinte*
"🎶 J'aime le filles de chez Castel. 🎶 "
Dans la vie
- Papa, maman j'ai quelque chose à vous dire
- Alexa, recommence ma musique.
*Alexa* "Très bien ! Je mets les lumières en vert!"
- Non, Alexa, recommence ma musique !
*Alexa* "Il fait actuellement 11 degrés à Oulan-Bator"
- C'est quoi le message que tu veux faire passer en fait le...
- Alexa recommence ma musique !
*Alexa* "La chanson de la raclette"
*musique* 🎶 Soirée raclette pour faire la fête 🎶
- Non, ça c'est la musique d'Enzo
- Bon ! J'aime les filles !
- On le sait ça en fait ma chérie
Mais là, ça c'est pas possible !
- Alexa, arrête !
*tous ensemble*
- Stop Alexa !
*la musique continue*
- Mais débranche le !!
Abonne-toi abonne toi !